Now here we have the earth,
Syene where the sun's rays strike vertically,
Alexandria where they strike at an angle α,
and this angle α is the same as this angle α,
and we're hoping we can use that to calculate the circumference.
Well, let's see.
We know there's 360 degrees in a full circle.
This alpha is going to represent some fraction of that 360 degrees--
maybe a half, maybe a quarter--we don't know yet.
What we do know is that the ratio of this length--
I'm going to call this length d--to the full circumference of the earth
must be equal to the ratio of this angle
over 360 degrees.
Now, I'll talk about that more in a second, but let's just write that down.
The ratio of this distance d to the full circumference of the earth
is also equal to the ratio of α to 360 degrees.
A good way to confirm that this equation makes sense
is let's think of some limiting cases.
What if α were 0? That would be a really, really tiny angle covering absolutely no distance.
0/360 = 0.
That would mean this length would have to be 0 as well. Good.
Now, what if α were a full 360 degrees?
What would d have to be for this formula to make sense?
Check the appropriate box.
Would d have to be 0, 1, or C--the circumference of the earth?